- On Fresh Prince,
I loved the show and I felt
like even back then it,
it talked about a lot of subjects
that were really important back then,
but sadly, I feel like still resonate now.
- Yes.
- What is that like,
like being a part, 'cause I know,
was it ever hard during the show?
'Cause y'all did, you brought up topics
that were hard topics
- Yes.
- to talk about and it
was such a family show.
- You know, we, we,
back then we used to always
laugh at it 'cause it was like
the very special episode of Fresh Prince.
- Yeah.
- Right.
And, and, and you know,
- Dramatic music.
- it was very dramatic.
It would be like something silly,
but, but we did, you
know, we, we touched on
I think because of the setup of the show
with Will coming from West
Philadelphia, moving to Bel Air,
the idea of rich and
poor, black and white,
black and other black, right?
Like, like how it, all
the dynamics of it all
and so the storylines
always seemed to work
because they came from real places.
- Yeah.
- They came from
real experiences that we
all had to deal with, right?
And so one episode where we're
pulled over by the police,
right and the idea that Carlton,
right, just was like,
he pulled us over because we're speeding,
it's not because we're black.
He would, he treated us this way because,
because he understood right and wrong.
That's all he, that's all he knew.
- Yeah.
- And so you could touch
on these subjects
without really being preachy
and really saying, this
is how it is, you know?
And I've heard Will say this many times,
it's like, you know, police
brutality didn't just start,
it's just being filmed.
- Yeah, I was gonna say,
- You know.
- I've heard people say that a lot,
it's been filmed now, yeah.
- It's just being filmed.
- Yeah.
- That's the difference.
This has always been happening.
- Yeah.
- And so,
and by the way, my dad's a cop,
my grandmother was a cop.
- Yeah.
- So I come from law enforcement,
but there is a reality,
there are good cops
and there are bad cops.
There are cops that do the right thing
and there are cops that
don't do the right thing,
just like all people,
right.
- Yeah.
- We are, we are in every aspect
of life, there are mirrors
and we are a mirror to
every aspect of, of society
and so what was wonderful
was being able to,
to say that and to show those stories
and to have those real conversations
and a lot of those
conversations happened on set
as we were getting ready
to film it, you know?
- But, and a lot of those conversations
happened in people's homes
after watching the episode.
- And that was the hope.
- With friends and, yeah
and that's the thing,
anytime you can, you know,
be a form of some kind of art
that, that is thought provoking
that makes people have those
conversations afterwards
- Yeah.
- job well done.
- Yeah well, it, it, it, see
that people seem to like it.
- You know what,
- They, they
- it is kind of successful.
- it's kind of stayed around
a little bit.
(laughing)
- Yeah, that Will Smith guy,
whatever happened to him.
- No one knows.